lundi politique gaël le dantec ils ont
été collègues au gouvernement elle a
soutenu pour la présidentielle de 2017
et depuis il appréciait distance pour
s'installer dans l'opposition quatre ans
elle aujourd'hui de la visite des
manières macron à la réunion le travail
parlementaire fait à paris que ce soit
contre les violences faites aux femmes
contre la vie chère pour la défense de
l'agriculture est il utile permet-il de
faire avancer les dossiers
quelle position adopter dans le climat
tendu autour de l'islam en france cannes
rôle quand elle joué lors des prochaines
échéances locales
eric à barèges députée socialiste et ex
ministre de l'outre-mer conseillère
municipale de saint denis est l'invité
lundi politique jusqu'à 13 heures sur la
première vos appels à partir de 12h45 au
02 62 99 2000 avec kabaret bonjour d'un
genre merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation enfin dans l'actualité il ya
évidemment la visite d' emmanuel macron
a tenu notre île mercredi pour 48 heures
après un passage par mayotte et par les
élus glorieuses quand on est député de
la réunion comment est-ce qu'on se
positionne lors se joue dans ce genre de
d'événements de déplacement est ce qu'on
accueille le président de façon
républicaine j'allais dire ce qu'on en
profite pour faire valoir sa différence
pour mettre en avant des revendications
une opposition mais écoutez moi je j'ai
choisi de
faire l'accueil républicain parce que je
crois qu'on a besoin comme ça de
référence important c'est le président
de la république nous sommes députés
députés de l'opposition je suis député
de l'opposition
mais c'est le président de toute la
république donc je ferai l'accueil
républicain à l'aéroport et au minimum
mort à saint denis
mais ensuite le président de la
république a choisi ce déplacement
pendant le débat en séance plénière à
l'assemblée nationale sur le projet de
loi de finances de la sécurité sociale
je suis membre de la commission des
affaires sociales j'étais la semaine
dernière en commission pour défendre des
budgets et des amendements et je vais
donc quitter le département mercredi
soir pour continuer le débat parce que
je pense que c'est un enjeu important
lorsque il y à 40% des personnes sous le
seuil de pauvreté d'aller débattre et
porter la voix de la réunion voir à
paris pour voir on va en parler
pour cette visite présidentielle les
syndicats de la réunion sont constitués
en intersyndicale quasiment tous les
syndicats y sont ils appellent à une
mobilisation jeudi
est-ce que vous soutenez cette démarche
est ce que c'est le bon moment pour les
syndicats pour se faire entendre
oui je pense que c'est le bon moment
pour se faire entendre parce que c'est
un moment particulier la visite de
président de la république pour la
première fois d'ailleurs en ce qui
concerne monsieur macron depuis qu'il
est président la république à la réunion
c'est le bon moment de faire entendre
notre voix parce que nous avons beaucoup
de choses à dire nous avons passé une
période difficile
la crise des gilet jaune l'année
dernière je rappelle que nous sommes le
seul département d'outre-mer qui avons
vécu ça et donc il est temps qu'il
entende ce qu'il n'entend pas à paris
est-ce que vous ressentez vous parliez
de la crise de gilet jaune est ce que
vous ressentez toujours cette colère
contre contre la vie chère mais aussi
contre les élus qui s'est exprimée l'an
dernier est ce qu'elle est toujours
présente
c est ce qu elle peut s'exprimer à cette
occasion il y a un grand grand rejet de
du gouvernement aujourd'hui de la
politique du gouvernement c'est de la
politique en général c'est la politique
en général et particulièrement la
politique du gouvernement
parce que aujourd'hui et ça va être
l'enjeu
la visite gouvernementale euh pardon du
président la république il faut qu'ils
parlent à tous les réunionnais et
lorsque je regarde le programme j'ai
l'impression qu'il va pas reparler qu'au
premier de cordée vous savez les
premiers de la classe qui au final ont
déjà presque tout ce qu'il faut mais je
n'ai pas vu dans le programme une
attention particulière pour tous ceux
qui sont derrière tous ceux qui vont
perdre en pouvoir d'achat
avec la réforme les réformes qui sont
portées par le gouvernement il est prévu
quand même qu'ils rencontrent des
membres de lo pmr oui sur un sujet
particulier c'est à dire j'imagine du
jour là la vie chère et puis ce serait
bien qu'on l'entende sur la
problématique de rachat et de vente qui
ce qui questionne beaucoup les
réunionnais aujourd'hui puis sa vision
aussi sur la concurrence sur la baisse
des prix sur la place de la production
locale que je défends depuis très
longtemps et qui avance petit à petit
donc il faut qu'on l'entende là dessus
mais oui il va rencontrer des chômeurs
je crois à saint paul
mais il ne va pas rencontrer tous ceux
qui vivent la pauvreté est là et qui va
basculer dans la grande pauvreté parce
que monsieur le dantec il faut que les
réunionnais le comprennent bien les 40 %
de personnes qui sont sous le seuil de
pauvreté qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté à la réunion
avec ce budget de la nation et le budget
de la sécurité sociale vont avoir zéro
euro en gains de pouvoir d'achat et même
vont perdre en pouvoir d'achat
pourquoi parce que toutes les
prestations sociales seront valorisés à
0,3 pour cent du coût de la vie
or le coût de la vie c'est-à-dire
l'inflation en france est un pur sang et
à la réunion lé cette inflation de 1,8
pour cent donc les écarts entre les plus
riches et les plus pauvres vont encore
se croisent et se creuser en france mais
encore plus à la réunion et je pense que
c'est à eux qu'il faut parler et pour
parler à ces personnes qui se battent et
qui vont se retrouver en difficulté
alimenter leurs enfants pour payer leur
loyer pour même se déplacer aller
chercher de travail et aller en
formation ces personnes ont besoin
d'être rassurés et d'être accompagné or
les mesures qui sont portées par
gouvernement aujourd'hui vont en sens
inverse et je vous le dis le pré on
applique vient accompagné d'une
délégation importante de ministres par
les duster de déplacement gouvernemental
c'est bien un déplacement présidentiel
mais avec un certain nombre de ministres
d'après nos informations bruno le maire
le ministre de l'économie
israël est alors s'il pourrait être du
voyage voilà d'après nous à confirmer
mais il pourrait être là en tout cas il
est prévu une séance économie avec cette
conférence qui devrait s'intituler deux
choses la réunion c'est une façon d la
voilà d'attirer les investisseurs
étrangers après tout est-ce que c'est
pas une bonne formule pour essayer de
créer de l'emploi de dynamiser
l'économie réunionnaise
oui mais j'allais dire on n'a pas
entendu chose la réunion lorsque nous
étions au gouvernement je le rappelle
quand même le chef le chômage avait
baissé énormément je rappelle qu'on
était à 30 % en 2012 et que nous sommes
à 24 % donc le chômage avait baissé nous
étions en créations d'emplois dans le
secteur marchand
le président va au salon etc si le salon
etc si je le rappelle je l'aï ouvert en
tant que ministre des outre mer déjà
qu'on avait accompagné les entreprises
par un 6e à 9 % et qu'aujourd'hui la
réalité c'est que ça va donner le temps
le medef comme si puisque le chômage
avait baissé de 30 à 24 % donc ça veut
quand on veut baisser l emploi mais
aujourd'hui la réalité
oui on aurait pu faire mieux exactement
et je vous rappelle que lorsque j'étais
venu dans vos studios
j'avais plaidé en tant que député pour
une contrepartie des aides que l'état
donne aux entreprises je maintiens cette
position il a joué aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce que je constate c'est que
eux ont détruit plus d'emplois qu'on en
crée et ça ça n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est le medef qui le dit puisque
on a créé 590 emplois mais on a perdu
1231 emplois sur la période fin 2018
début 2019
donc aujourd'hui et la dire le dis aussi
les réformes du gouvernement ne crée pas
suffisamment d'emplois et je pense qu'il
faut être effectivement sur les deux
jambes il faut être sur la jambe de
dynamique économique soutenir les
petites entreprises soutenir l'activité
économique ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et dans le même temps
soutenir c'est ce qu'on avait mis en
place qu'il aurait fallu mieux évaluer
pour plus d'efficacité
le gouvernement a décidé de couper de
façon dure dans ce qui existait pour
proposer une autre réforme qui a été mis
en place l'année dernière
très critiquée par le monde de
l'économie puisque aujourd'hui avec
cette réforme il y à une perte sèche
pour les entreprises puisque il y assure
des salaires qui tourne autour de 2700
euros nets donc d'encadrement dans les
entreprises réunionnaises
il y à un surcoût des messes des
salaires autour de 6%
si vous voulez bien on tire vers le bas
les salaires à la réunion avec ce
système qui a été mis en place par
gouvernement et dans le même temps en un
vrai problème de pouvoir d'achat
donc il ya quelque chose qui est
illogique de la délégation set cette
semaine être exprimé aussi sur les
parcours en partance qui remplace les
contre-allées aussi que la suppression
en très forte diminution des emplois à
poser de deux graves problèmes comme une
merde ou
lectra est ce que vous êtes vous
favorable à remettre du contrat aidé et
financé plus où est ce que vous dites
après tout ce parcours en plein
compétences qu'elles remplacent c'est
bien c'est une formule il faut aller il
faut lire ça ou est ce que il faut
définitivement l'écart du vrai emploi et
est tournée doit ces contrats aidés il
fallait faire du vrai emploi
très clairement il n'y a aucun sujet là
dessus il n'y a jamais eu d'ailleurs de
sujets là dessus c'est pour ça qu'on est
des aides pour que les entreprises
puissent embaucher à des salaires
convenables
les gens qui ont des diplômes les gens
qui ont des formations adéquates
donc ça c'est le premier pas le deuxième
point il suffit d'interroger l'en a
délogée
ce qui on le paie qu'aujourd'hui ce qui
on le paie qu'aujourd'hui vous dise le
parcours sera compétences vous dise
aujourd'hui mais ça n'est pas du tout
efficace pourquoi parce qu'on est passé
de contrat à deux ans un contrat à peine
maman qu'est ce que vous faites
maintenant le temps d'arriver sur un
poste de comprendre le poste de
comprendre l'entreprise à voir les
restes il passe trois mois quatre mois
cinq mois et après vous devez partir de
6 mois après donc il ya une espèce de
stress continu qui accompagnent ces
personnes très éloignées de l'emploi et
qui dégrade la sortie positif de ces
gens qui sont qui ont envie de saint
céré qu on vit travaillé ah non ça n'est
pas suffisant le deuxième point c'est
que nous on n'avait obtenu que l'aide de
l'état pour avoir beaucoup de contrats
et donc traiter massivement cette entrée
dans l'insertion par l'activité
professionnelle
c'était une aide plus conséquente aux
entreprises puisque vous savez qu'il y
avait un avis mis en place les contrats
aidés dans le secteur marchand pu mais
aussi les collectivités locales
on était autour de 80 voire 95 % des
aides de l'état 50%
donc du coup on en fait - et donc du
coup du coup tout ce encore une fois
qu'ils ont le plus besoin d'être pris
par la main pour entrer de façon
bienveillante dans un processus
d'insertion de professionnalisation ils
sont mis de côté et aujourd'hui le
vivent très mal enfin je n'invente rien
il suffit d'interroger les gens
véritablement faut plus de contrats
aidés
et puis vous savez un très concrètement
on est dans une approche tellement
technocrates tellement compliqué la
dégradation de l'accueil dans les
services publics que ce soit la caf que
ce sont services fiscaux que ce soit à
pôle emploi
interrogés les gens ils ont besoin parce
qu'ils doivent être rassurés parce
qu'ils sont en situation fragile
ils ont besoin d'être dans des
entretiens avec des personnes qui
écoutent qu'il est qu'ils ont ce camp là
or aujourd'hui comme on diminue la les
effectifs des services publics
ce temps d'accompagnement n'existe plus
non plus ses couleurs mais parce que ça
coûte cher mais ce qui coûte cher aussi
c'est les réformes qui ont été faites il
y a deux ans lorsque on transforme on
fait disparaître l'impôt sur la grande
fortune on met l'impôt sur la fortune
immobilière qu'on met à flat tax c'est
les cadeaux qu'on fait aux vraiment aux
plus riches d'entre nous il faut savoir
que sur ces réformes leurs les 5% les
plus riches de france ont gagné près de
6500 euros avec juste la réforme de la
flat tax est ce que c'était vraiment
nécessaire
est-ce qu'on ne pouvait pas mettre 5
milliards pour tirer vers le haut le
plus de monde possible et après engrangé
une politique dans
sur vers le tout emploi quand les gens
sont déjà à un niveau stabilisé et de
formation et de volonté de possibilité
d'entrer dans du travail la vie chez
rhodia tout cas dans l'engagement télé
toujours une préoccupation majeure
peut-être la relocation principal le
rachat de d'indéniables robert ayotte
est venu dans le sens talibans de débats
sur la question de la vie chère ici la
réunion vous ça vous inquiète
mais est ce que le politique est ce que
est ce que les élus doivent ou peuvent
intervenir dans ce débat qui finalement
ils jouent plus concurrencé pris à
témoin ce que le politique
alors le politique en général mais après
on peut venir sur le maire le sénateur
pépite extra mais la politique est là
pour porter une vision comme territoire
il faut que chacun nous puissions dire
comment est ce que nous voyons
aujourd'hui nos territoires et comment
nous le voyons à dix ou vingt ans dans
le temps donc ça c'est le premier point
ensuite sur donc il faut qu'on dise il
faut qu'on dise ce qu'on pense de ça la
deuxième chose nous on y travaille on
est à travailler là avec l'eau pmr et 50
citoyens en particulier on a beaucoup
produit on a beaucoup réfléchi on a une
position qui était très clair sur le
rachat de 20 des mia par gbh avec une
position qui a été partagée au niveau
national même sur certains points parce
que lorsque je dis ici il faut un
moratoire pour ne plus avoir de grande
distribution qui sortent pour préserver
les terres réunionnaises et puis parce
que je crois que le modèle est arrivé le
modèle unique grande distribution est
arrivé au bout eh ben cette position
maintenant elle est partagée au niveau
national par des députés de la majorité
nous avons travaillé sur un rat mort
parlementaire sur la vendit stature
nationale
rabon est sorti le mois dernier dans la
vôtre contribuer sur ce qu'il ressent
c'est que le modèle de leur distribution
une faste pour la production il faut en
changer enfin jean pattes de modèles
comme ça d'ailleurs c'est ce que vous
dites est très vrai lorsque pendant la
crise est au tout début de cette
mandature
j'entendais la ministre et outre-mer
dire y'a qu'à faut que puis tout d'un
coup on va tout changer on va régler le
problème de la vie chère
non ça se passe pas comme ça dans la
vraie vie dans la vraie vie il y à des
systèmes et des tissus qui sont
organisés non depuis même la
colonisation cette économie de comptoir
qui assoient des situations en opale
elle a perduré la loi lurel 2012 a
bousculé pas mal les choses
et aujourd'hui on va même plus loin avec
le rapport de cette commission denquête
donc non on ne renverse pas la table
comme ça mais oui on peut avoir des
décisions très importantes comme le
moratoire pour ne plus sortir de grandes
surfaces à la réunion pour présenter son
projet ils sont pas ils ont pas été
validé tous les projets qui sont dans le
tuyau qui n'ont pas été validées
maintenant par encore par la commission
de validation et qu' on n'est pas dans
un système tout ou rien il ya un
équilibre à trouver
il ya la grande distribution qui
existent et qu'ils voient qu'on va pas
faire disparaître pascal d'emploi et
parce que c'est nécessaire parce que ça
répond à un vrai besoin
voilà dans certains cas mais au pas dans
tous les cas parce que si c'était le cas
on n'aurait pas eu le problème de la
liche à rien parce que si la réponse aux
prix bas pour les produits de
consommation était et la grande
distribution
on n'aurait pas eu de crise à rien
puisque notre seul modèle de
propositions consommateurs c'est la
grande distribution
donc il est un vrai sujet on propose
quelque chose qui soit disant va faire
baisser les prix et ne répond pas à la
question
ce n'est pas le bon projet
il faut compléter cela par le
développement de commerces de proximité
d'abord parce que pourquoi je prends
l'exemple d'abord parce qu'on s'urbanise
énormément les villes grossistes que la
population vieillit elle va doubler dans
les 20 prochaines années et je ne crois
pas en ayant des grandes surfaces très
éloignées des centres de vie va pouvoir
répondre aux besoins des personnes
vieillissantes
donc il ya un changement démographique
il ya un changement de l'aménagement
donc il faut soutenir et le troisième
point c'est que je pense qu'il faut
mettre le paquet le paquet sur une
production locale et ça c'est ma
conviction depuis des années une
production locale où les gens peuvent
produire de la qualité pour nourrir les
réunionnaises et réunionnais qu'est ce
qu'ils m'ont aidé et le tc mons et la
volonté c'est la volonté
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui du
gouvernement a raison prenons ce cas là
on est monté au créneau tous ensemble
avec les débuts des sénateurs de
nombreuses fois ça fait des mois que
nous soutenons les filières pour la
diversification aujourd'hui je vous
passe sur les aspects techniques in man
2 millions d'euros pas 2 milliards de
millau compagnie la subvention de
filières économiques au monde et on ne
peut pas trouver deux millions pour
sauver
en attendant qu'on ait une vraie volonté
politique de structuration de l'ensemble
des filières à la réunion trouver deux
millions d'euros pour sauver cette
filière il faut ça ensuite il faut ce
grand projet mais on n'a plus besoin
d'écrire quoi que ce soit ça a été écrit
mille fois les livres bleus il faut le
faire les livres blancs etc
on connait tous ça fait 40 ans les gens
travaillent pour structurer les filières
donc maintenant il faut mettre les
moyens les moyens humains les terres
aussi il faut avoir une gestion
rationnelle de cette terre réunionnaise
qui part à vau l'eau et a plu par sony
jarratt à rennes
sca qui veut prend ses acquis soit de
faire ce qu'il veut prends ça n'est plus
possible
on a besoin de terre pour la sécurité
alimentaire je veux dire ça parce que
c'est pas important
à chaque fois qu'on vit une crise
qu'elles soient économiques et sociales
qu'elles sont environnementale un
cyclone etc
on se retrouve avec des bateaux ou des
avions qui n'arrivent pas sur le
territoire
la responsabilité politique d'un
politique c'est de se poser la question
comment je nourris la population le jour
où les bateaux n'arrivent plus est-ce
que ça c'est de constater aujourd'hui on
n'a pas de réponse
c'est à l'état parce que c'est la région
qui qui doit avoir cette vision doit
l'utiliser le monde donc je crois tout
le monde
c'est pour ça qu'il ya une collectivité
aujourd'hui à la cense un politique qui
a sept sénateurs
là la responsabilité politique majeure
et globale aujourd'hui de la vision
c'est la région puisque la région a la
compétence d'aménagement économique de
formation professionnelle donc ça n'est
pas rien quand même de coopération
régionale parce que la coopération
régionale est un élément très important
dans la sécurité alimentaire
et puis elle département puisque vous
savez que le domaine agricole est aussi
géré par le département
et puis il ya les collectivités
municipales parce que nous avons encore
sur les mairies une compétence
d'aménagement avec le plus qui permet de
geler plus bruns et d'aménager les
terres communales en fonction d'un
schéma d'aménagement régional qui est
porté par la région
vous voyez tout ce monde où tout ce
monde-là sam rigo et et et il faut par
exemple lorsqu'on est en cours de
révision du sar qu'il y ait un vrai
débat
il est où le débat sur sa télé publique
en cours
les gens sont pris dans leurs
préoccupations quand on ne dit pas les
choses quand on n'interpelle pas quand
on ne favorise pas le débat le débat ne
se passe pas et puis la réponse après ce
deuxième but mais il y avait la
consultation oui mais si on veut
vraiment que les gens viennent il faut
les solides
et il faut les amener à réfléchir autour
de ce cet élément majeur quand vous êtes
une île plus qu'ailleurs encore et que
vous avez 2500 kilomètres carrés mille
kilomètres carrés
affecté à nourrir la population
logée la population éduquer la
population à accueillir les
établissements pour les personnes âgées
qui vont doubler dans les 20 prochaines
années dit aménagé pour qu'on ait de la
production écologique sur ce territoire
il faut nous dire comment est ce qu'on
peut ensemble réfléchir et construire ce
territoire pour porter cette ambition
l'ambition finale elle et elle est assez
basique
comment je protège la population
réunionnaise et comme enjeu la projette
dans une dynamique de création de
richesses et d'emplois pour qu'enfin il
y ait moins de pauvreté est plus de
considération vis à vis de ces
populations de la région il va sûrement
être question de duchaussoy long du
littoral aussi pensais tu finissais
puisqu'il semblerait que joue racistes
tenus par le secrétaire d'état chargé
aux transports sont également du voyage
vous exprimer l'essence sur ce dossier
quelle lecture nous en fait aujourd'hui
et dès qu'on sort de ces sièges sont un
peu un peu les points sans même si des
accords ont été signés entre en scène
avant ce terme de dead jachère on est
dans une situation qui est
incompréhensible
un conte principe pour personne on passe
maintenant d'aller la presse nationale
on nous regarde en me disant mais
comment vous avez fait ça comment vous
avez pu lancer un projet à deux
milliards dans un milliard 6 et les
accords de matignon
un aménagement majeur sans avoir pris la
précaution de prévoir la matière
première pour faire 7
cet aménagement majeur
et c'est vrai que au niveau national
quand on pose la question on a beaucoup
de difficulté à répondre comment on peut
répondre à ça n'importe qui comprend
quand il va faire son prêt à la banque
pour construire sa maison avant il fait
les blancs ils voient les entreprises et
y vérifie que tout le monde va bien les
matériaux pour pouvoir faire sa maison
parce que sinon ils payent le prêt et la
maison et là bas ça c'est le premier
prix et c'est incompréhensible parce que
j'ai regardé élu avec beaucoup
d'attention
l'avis de l'autorité environnementale
rendu en 2011
le républicain l'auteur écrit lui et en
2011 l'autorité environnementale dit
plusieurs choses mais elle dit une chose
elle dit vous allez choisir puisque la
région avait choisi la digue et et le
viaduc et elle dit vous avez choisi ça
j'attire votre attention sur le fait qu'
il vous faudra 10 millions de tonnes de
roches et que en l'état de ce que je
vois votre schéma départemental des
carrières
vous n'allez pas trouver ces 10 millions
de tonnes si vous ne réalisez pas les
choses pourquoi parce que le schéma
départemental des carrières de 2010
avaient été construits non pas avec la
nouvelle route du littoral
mais avec le tram train donc les
demandes et les besoins en pierre et
qualité pierre n'était pas du tout les
mêmes
mais cette révision du schéma et elles
ont des ministres hâtives mais le
chantier et c'est un ca global it est
sauvée dans une bonne question juste de
dégrafer loi administrative sur des deux
mondes qui ont été retardés de deux
mauvaise prise en compte des
recommandations environnementales ou
esthétique et plus profondément bloqués
moi je crois qu'on est sur un dossier
plus profondément bloqué parce que
il y à des questions légitimes qui se
pose pourquoi en 2011 les choses n'ont
pas été faites en bonne et due forme en
respectant le droit et non pas comme des
2014 2015 2016 et c'est essayer de
passer en contournement du droit et
d'ailleurs ça ne passe pas parce que le
juge
heureusement on regarde que moi donc ça
ne passe pas on veut passer en force
pourquoi en 2011
on ne fait pas les choses comme il
aurait fallu faire alors au départ randy
winn ça va être long mais 11 2011 + 6
ans voire 7 ans en 2018 2018 on est dans
les temps
donc tout va bien mais on ne le fait pas
et donc une question des rires ça
pourquoi on l'a pas fait je n'ai pas de
réponse mais c'est une vraie question
qui pose la question de la légitimité de
la décision du et puis la gouvernance de
ce dossier par le président de région
c'est une vraie question
et c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il est
temps que l'état qui contribuent en tout
cas dans les accords de matignon
un montant plus élevé que la région
reprennent les choses en un
parce qu'aujourd'hui la gouvernance a
amené la région a amené la région
réunion c'est à dire la réunion dans une
impasse
incroyable qui va plomber le budget
régional qu'il va entraîner qui vont
entraîner la réunion dans un trou noir
énorme parce qu'aujourd'hui quand
j'écoute la région
je ne vois pas les propositions de
sorties il n'y a aucune proposition
sortie si ce n'est de dire c'est pas moi
c'est lui
ça ça n'est pas des propositions c'est
pas digne d'un responsable politique sur
l'actualité
qui vous intéressent assemblée nationale
répondait traite de retraite et sur la
table les débats sont organisés en ce
moment par le gouvernement quelle est
votre position quelques mots sur cette
réforme qui est présenté comme
oligatoires nécessaire alors nous on
sera vraiment très vigilant on a
commencé les auditions à écouter les uns
et les autres nous ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui si je reprends juste pour la
réunion par exemple où on a déjà
interrogé le ministre là dessus c'est de
dire il va falloir quand même regarder
cette singularité là pourquoi première
chose c'est qu'on a toujours vécu un
schéma structurel à la réunion donc par
conséquent des gens qui ont moins cotisé
non pas par volonté mais parce qu'ils
rient pas d'offre de travail ensuite on
a eu l'égalité sociale en 1996 donc ce
sont des gens qui ont un quotidien non
pas de leur fait mais parce qu'il n'y
avait pas d'égalité sur ce territoire
est aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation qui sert en a les qualités
sociales mais non nous n'avons pas
encore l'emploi en ligne de mire donc il
faudra quand même traité l'approchent
et puis nous avons les retraites
agricoles donc il faudra traiter quand
même avec peut-être une singularité
c'est ce que nous avons devant blé les
départements d'outre-mer et la réunion
en particulier avec à un moment donné
bien sûr une ancré dans le droit commun
nous sommes dit inquiet parce que
justement aujourd'hui nous voyons que le
projet de loi c'est que de financement
de la sécurité sociale fait que tout ce
qui est sécurité sociale et budget
social de ce budget social étant
demandes d'efforts encore très très
grand y compris pour l'hôpital et on se
dit si on commence une réforme de la
retraite dans un environnement très
contraint où on demande des efforts à ce
budget de financement de la sécurité
sociale ça augure quand même des efforts
qui vont être encore demandé aux plus
faibles d'entre nous on lit 12 45 les
auditeurs participer à cette émission
poser des questions à travers une
première
question de stéphane qui est tout
téléphone avec nous pouvons faire avec
notamment sur mon bureau
la première c'est un article que vous
avez fendu dans la presse locale sur une
pleine page concernant le rachat du
groupe vindémia par le groupe marriott
on est bien d'accord oui et bien donc je
m'interroge sur votre position dans cet
article que vous décrivez noir sur blanc
à l'attention des réunionnais finalement
je pense aussi des dionysiens et en même
temps une majorité municipale qui
s'accomplit en pré grille mais avec ce
même groupe b marriott pour l'ouverture
d'une prochaine grande surface sur le
site petit devant le stade de l'est à
saint-denis et il ya quelques secondes
vous parlez de 110 ans d'un moratoire
qu'on ne plus voir faire sortir devant
de surface sur tout territoire national
est ce que vous avez dit mais même pour
ce territoire aride où vous ne voulez
pas l'appliquer puisque votre majorité
municipale va donc ouvrir une nouvelle
grande surface et donne du terrain donne
encore du grain à moudre à ce groupe
bernard hayot
alors merci à la fin ce sera la pétition
du monde et magog personnes qui flatte
lehman pour gagner et exploiter leurs
saveurs politiciens démagogues
je n'invente rien c'est le dictionnaire
robert pires ennemis du rock et de fait
définition des bagues org
merci pour votre question qui veut que
les réponses merci mon cher stéphane
pour cette question claire et franche
non je suis pas
démagogue en tout cas vous lisez très
bien le dictionnaire
non je vous expliquais deux choses
d'abord quand on est en responsabilité
est qu'on a un mandat moi je suis député
de la république je n'écris pas un
article pour les dionysiens j'écris un
article pour les réunionnaises et les
réunionnais pour toute la réunion est la
conviction que je porte c'est la mienne
et j'ai une totale liberté dans les
pensées et dans les combats que je mène
et je n'ai l'intention de demander
l'autorisation à quiconque
donc je porte ce combat non pas depuis
aujourd'hui et le problématique du
rachat de vindémia mais depuis longtemps
depuis une dizaine d'années et ça s'est
exprimé d'une part parce que la loi leur
aile et d'autre part par la loi égalité
réelle alors ce qui concerne le projet
devons parler il ne s'agit pas d'une
grande surface
il s'agit de l'installation de décathlon
sur une zone de prix mais je pense que
c'est un peu différent et ça montre bien
enfin bien sûr ce qui prouve enfin que
je ne fais pas de ce combat un combat
exclusivement arrêté sur le nom d'un de
monsieur ayotte
je pose globalement le sujet au delà de
mayotte
je pose le sujet de du moratoire sur les
grandes surfaces je dis bien les grandes
surfaces qui font du bazar qui font de
l'alimentation ils font des vitrines
pour des magasins diverses et variées
voilà la vraie question
donc voilà j'espère que j'ai éclaircies
un peu plus précisément les
questionnements que vous vous posiez
merci pour ce très bon jeu sur sa
question qui était volontairement
dionysienne est ce que ces combattants
section municipale
je serai sur la liste 1 qui sera fait
pour ce rendez-vous mars 2000 bas donc
oui je serai en ce sens candidate sur
l'a10 pour les municipales de 2010 qui
sera conduite rangelov une liste qui
sera conduite par gilbert annette
c'est officiel c'est clair c'est ce que
vous dites les uns et les autres dont
les noms nous aurons notre meeting de
lancement de campagne
14 novembre
jeudi 14 novembre dont je vous invite
tous les jeunes qui est ce que et son
pouvoir en cas de l'histoire pop star
les prochains échanges
non moi je suis enfin vraiment j'ai des
combats oui et non c'est pas la question
c'est la question c'est qu'il faut qu'on
sorte et il faut que je joue le rôle que
j'ai à jouer aujourd'hui là où je suis
pour faire sortir la réunion de des
difficultés énormes auxquelles on se
trouve vraiment c'est plus facile autre
que d'éviter que ça n'est pas facile
lorsqu'on est lui conçoit municipal
député région département c'est toujours
très compliqué et c'est pour cette
raison que les élus doivent être
extrêmement rigoureux sur l'exercice de
leurs fonctions rigoureux et exigeant
lorsqu on va se battre sur les causes
qui sont complexes techniques où on nous
attend au tournant la population des
sursis qui doivent décider où nous
proposer des solutions aux standards un
autre stéphane une question pour vous de
saint-andré on vous écoutera merci de
poser votre question d'héritage
animateurs charles dutoit moreau
vice-président de l'association kodom
début mai chez en notre lutte il que
l'on consacré à la défense des concepts
2006 actuellement en tête mais le
fonctionnaire ultraman actu réunionnais
mais le tram à arrêt du général dont il
y avait été ministre de l'outre-mer
vous serez présente pour le déplacement
du président emmanuel macron est ce que
vous pourriez porter cette thématique
lors de son déplacement pour enfin avoir
des réponses aux questions avec un
gouvernement qui voulait porter une
réforme en cinq mois on se rend compte
que neuf mois après il n'y a toujours
rien je dois te décris toujours pas de
circulaire est ce que vous voulez encore
une fois bien nous faire l'honneur
d'être la porte parole merci merci ca
pour c'était l'interdît avec le présent
et vous pouvez nous avons sur l'agent du
oui
d'abord moi je voulais saluer le travail
que fait le podium un simple travail qui
norme où ils remettent à chaque fois le
sujet sur la table parce que les
réformes qui sont proposés monsieur à 10
et doit être fait en cinq mois nous
ferons après y'a rien n'y a pas de
transparence on s'est rendu avec
nassimah dindar à un rendez-vous avec le
cabinet du ministre darmanin et monsieur
du soft pour redire mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait et partager votre réflexion et
écouter ce que les uns et les autres
disent on a jamais de réponse c'est
vraiment cette façon de faire qui est
insupportable et qui laissent des
familles entières sans réponse alors que
je rappelle à ce sujet et des mutations
et de de la réforme des congés bonifiés
parce que c'est un peu lié quand même
sur la limitation il y à une loi la loi
égalité réelle
il suffit de l'appliquer et le
gouvernement ne veut pas l'appliquer
malgré les montées au créneau que nous
faisons tous les associations et les
politiques ça ne marche pas il ya des
sceaux lui il ya des situations d'une
violence extrême et fanny qui sont
séparés des enfants qui n'ont plus leur
papa ou leur maman fin on est au bord de
ce qui est supportable sur les congés
bonifiés
c'est aujourd'hui le gouvernement qui
dit grosso modo on va répartir les
congés bonifiés sur l'année au lieu
d'aller une fois tous les 3 mois ce sera
plus souvent sauf que derrière ça ne
convient pas à tout le monde
donc oui je continuerai à porter et même
si pendant cette visite du président
la république je peux lui ni ses et si
vous me transmettez les documents je lui
laisserai votre contribution est en
votre nom
mais on doit continuer ce combat qui est
un combat qui extrêmement difficile
j'espère qu'on finira par le aigner
parce que c'est justice on va à une
autre question sont à repousser joseph
qui est temps de vous demander d'être
présent les choses et parce que oui bon
dites moi dans les détails mais quand on
parle du gouvenement les lois et ceci et
cela
je vais vous poser une question ce matin
j'ai lu dans le journal que le parti
communiste réunionnais voulais je les
lui le tonneau me et ceci et cela
et quand je vous entends pour moi la
réunion c'est une été acquis et de
crédit on peut planter n'importe où on
peut faire n'importe quoi je voudrais
voir vos plantations
surtout que la piste d'autonomie fait
pas partie de ce que je voudrais merci
féministe mais vous avez vous avez
encore épaissi passion à l'autonomie
l'émancipation
c'est à dire la capacité qu'on a
aujourd'hui parce qu'on gère les fonds
européens parce qu'on a des dotations
parce qu on a certains pouvoirs donnés
par la loi et les lois de
décentralisation on allait pouvoir
aujourd'hui à la réunion de décider de
nombreuses choses sans aller à chaque
fois pleurer pour trouver des solutions
à paris la troisième la dernière chose
que je pense qu'il faut réformer la
constitution pour faire disparaître mon
envie rappelé pour qu'on ait plus vers
des décisions plus adapté à nos
territoires et avoir cette possibilité
de le faire ici à la réunion
et ça ça s'appelle l'émancipation et
palau de france au sommet de l'état on
se reconnaît sensible
assez tendue vous dites c'est bien ces
débats où le ratio il ya eu dérapage
dangereux quand la voix de la réunion
sur ce sujet toujours sensible alors moi
j'ai essayé de faire entendre la voix la
semaine dernière parce que je faisais le
point de presse pour le groupe
j'ai parlé de la réunion et je trouve qu
à chaque fois qu une élection chaque
fois qu'il ya un choix on utilise le
voile on utilise l'islamisation on
utilise la radicalisation pour tout
mettre dans le même panier et pour
opposer les français entre eux donc
c'est une mauvaise façon de faire et
j'ai expliqué qu'à la réunion on était
un modèle particulier alors ça peut
paraître idyllique pour les français de
l'hexagone mais c'est la réalité pour
nous et donc je ne participerai pas à
moi à les débats il consiste juste à
mettre au pilori des français de
confession musulmane par contre je pense
qu'on a un vrai problème sur la
radicalisation et sur lequel en
confessions rayons on a des cas de
radicalisation la réunion bien sûr
ministre on l'avait eu à regarder ce
sujet donc il faut toujours se protéger
contre ce à 15,9 de votre parti les
jumeaux respectueux les presser de la
pluie qui doivent faire entendre leur
voix
c'est au juge de dire oui à tout le
monde de le dire est ce justement qui
porte ce vivre ensemble j'étais samedi à
la remise de la légion d'honneur
de d'un musulmans réunionnais qui fait
partie de ces familles qui ont construit
la réunion monsieur iqbal en gare et
pour la petite histoire et ça ça
n'existe pas en france hexagonale
son parrain c'était monseigneur gilbert
aubry est bien juste que ça juste ça ça
n'existe pas voilà en france
il faut qu'ils arrivent hexagonal il
faut qu'ils arrivent à comprendre que ça
c'est possible
le ça ça existe mais parce que il ya une
certaine façon de vivre l'islam
respectueuse des règles de la république
tout en faisant que les enfants aillent
aussi allez me dire ça c'est possible et
que les mamans portent le voile pour
aller chercher leurs enfants à la sortie
d'école ça aussi c'est possible merci
lundi politique passé une excellente
journée sur la première
merci
rien à tes jean-marie sont pas de